what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the official trailer
or trailer dose for the Marvels John how are you I
am marvelous Gregory how are you oh my God that is
good anyway guys listen up John and Greg are
going to be heading out to Comic-Con tomorrow
because we have a panel at Comic Con Saturday
at one o'clock P.M so if you are there please go
attend our panel love to say hi to you secondly
we obviously have had merch with a Zero edition
that partnership is coming to an end at the end of
this month and here's a shirt called a soda that
we were going to launch in August but because the
partnership is coming to an end now we only have
it available literally for just like 10 days when
I say limited time I mean it after July 31st it's
not going to be selling anymore at all so if you
guys want to get yourself in a soda shirt please
go ahead and do it I got one coming in the mail
right now I'm excited to wear it when the Ahsoka
series comes out anywho guys let's watch this
Marvel's trailer and see what it's all about
yeah Danvers prodigal child of the Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of Entry
how goes it out there no air space right
nice Marvel logo be annihilator
and now I'm returning the favor
okay oh she got the bangle yeah
they're linked
so we switch places whenever we use them
Theory you can absorb light I can see it
and Kamala who's Kamala hi she can turn
light into physical matter which I have
never heard of I could totally show you
oh my
sweet whoa
[Music]
everything and everyone oh serving every planet we
call home Thor Ragnarok walks here I would never
choose to bring anybody into this you are not the
only thing standing between this and the universe
pre-war rages on slurkin crossovers
yourself higher higher for the
faster further faster baby [Music]
I can't can you I got it
[Laughter]
that made me cooler I should have you take that
eye much sooner well that was a fun trailer sure
didn't really feel like I got too much new from
it but I did get a better sense of where Carol
Danvers is at in particular what her Arc might be
it seems like that this is going to be the kind
of thing where she she is like I gotta go Rogue
I gotta do this on my own this is something I can
handle the kind of the impression I'm getting is
that she's been handling a lot of stuff by herself
for such a long time that she probably feels
like she can handle this on her own and it's
interesting going off of secret Invasion where
they had Nick Fury with this certain Mission and
he's like this is personal this is something
I cause now you you're bringing him here and
Carol Danvers also kind of a similar thing like
personal Vendetta between her and the uh what's
it called the Korea accusers what she's rumored to
be playing at least and so I I like that personal
entanglement so I like that personal entanglement
and then of course having to work through with
Monica of you know whatever forgiveness that she
has to go through so there's some good Arc set up
there where you probably have Kamala as more
lore and fun I mean she still looks like the
best part of the trailers to me she's still my
favorite part uh from everything we got weirdly
even though I didn't feel like I got much new in
terms of plot I still thought it was actually a
better trailer I would absolutely agree this felt
way more smooth and I mean certainly they clearly
communicate a couple things about the strangeness
of what's happening to them and yeah them all
zapping into the You Know Places each other was
at the point they used their powers but yeah this
just felt a lot more fleshed out and full and the
like quirky fun bits felt proportional to the bits
that were supposed to be more like War heavy you
know seeing stuff that does hearken to like the
craze grow war that wages on despite this peace
treaty with the the zandarians or whatever you're
not getting a giant glance at like the climactic
scenes I don't get the sense except for this one
big splash page fight at the end of the trailer
certainly where they're all sort of fighting in
unison but you do get more of like the intensity
of the threat of the villain whereas the first
teaser just kind of gave me like some cookies
happening to the the Marvels right now one thing
that I'm really excited for too when I see all
this imagery we're getting Monica Rambo and of
course we're gonna get Kamala Khan who we saw in
a television series and now while you know Disney
plus they often throw so much money at their
television shows simultaneously it's still a
television show it wouldn't be the same kind of
budget or focus of what you would put towards the
visual effects and realizing their powers coming
to fruition in a cinematic type of experience
right I'm really excited for working out kind of
like when you watch like the Power Rangers show
and then you got the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
movie you're like wow it's like from the show but
better looking yeah yeah they had money for actual
film grades or film stocks and things and yes real
big sets but yeah well for their visual Powers as
well you know for Monica's powers and then also
especially for kamala's Powers I feel like when we
see that on the big screen that's gonna look even
cooler when you're comparing it to a television
show but as it stands you know for a trailer I
thought that was fine I think it's still a weird
time for the trailer to be coming out when secret
invasion is still currently airing you know so man
there might lend some Credence to the theory that
the Nick fear that we're watching here might be a
scroll sure who knows uh but I still think it's a
little bit odd that they would release this before
secret invasion is done which kind of seems to
undermine some of the stakes in some degree when
I'm like well I feel like that chapter is going
to be fine now I feel like you would want to put
this out right after your finale or something like
that or something to to give people that extra
reminder that yes these are connected but also
yes not to undercut what's happening with secret
Invasion yeah well outside of that though uh I do
feel like we're gonna get a better vision of you
know Brie Larson's Charisma yes I felt like that
was something that was absent in the first one
because I think she is a great actress if you
watch interviews with her I think she's actually
a really Charming actress despite what half the
internet seems to think about her I actually
find her to be a very Charming personality and
I really feel like that's present here and to
give her like the the other actors to be able
to bounce off of and that was something that I'm
hoping the movie is really going to deliver on is
the kind of interplay between the three of them
like if we're talking about secret Invasion one
of the things I'm loving about the show is just
the scene work right and then if you got three
great actresses sharing the screen together I'm
really excited to see how they interact with one
another especially because you have you know
kamala's of reverence that she feels towards
you know Captain Marvel then you got Monica with
her childhood history it's her auntie right there
yeah yeah yeah that her caribence is that she's
also feeling that she has to overcome that we're
hinted at in Wanda Vision I think there's just a
lot of great character work that we could also get
here and right now they're still leaning towards
just a fun popping visuals when I like the Beastie
Boys song and it's very apt uh for particularly
this movie I'm still not really getting quite
as good like the plot doesn't seem crazy enough
or intense enough or anything like high stakes
caliber enough to me to currently you know like
maybe it's more quirky than like Earth bending
or World shattering necessarily and maybe it just
wants to be just fun but they got Nia DeCosta here
who I feel needed Costa can bring like a Punch
Yeah and dramatic you know heft yeah while I
like a lot of the way the the visuals are looking
for the most part and while I like a lot of the
um the interchanging when they are switching
between sets and powers and all that I think
that all looks really cool and maybe this will
lead more into something with the Multiverse
perhaps this can lead to some incursions I
really don't know exactly where it's gonna go
right now I'm like yeah I mean this looks
this looks fine this looks like really this
is entertaining uh it doesn't look exceptional
to me just yet but maybe that's just enough for
people to be like I just want to walk out and just
have a really fun time and at the end of the day I
feel like that's all I'm really gonna ask for
is I just want to have a fun time uh but when
you're telling me about these three characters
here finally crossing over and then you need to
Costa I feel like it has the potential to be great
yeah like a big punctuation statement and I mean
one thing I do I am heartened by is the fact
that all the characters here look except for
Kamala Khan because she is so new they're all more
comfortable in their lot and in what they're doing
what their mission is and like Nick Fury way more
laid back than when he and Carol first met so like
I feel like there's a lot of potential for that
kind of like better more engaging personal drama
but yeah I don't know if this movie is aiming to
be like Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania trying
to be like a huge chapter you know essential to
this or if it just is focused on trying to be the
Captain Marvel movie that people will really meet
and receive and sometimes I get that that's not
always about shooting to the highest Stakes it's
about shooting to some more middle personal Stakes
that are maybe hard to pitch in like a blockbuster
trailer but yeah like at the same time because
so many powerhouses are combining I get why you
would want this to feel like a momentous kind of
punctuation occasion yeah yeah but as it stands
guys I mean we're of course gonna see this you
know opening night or earlier if we're fortunate
enough to so yeah we'll definitely be there
and we'll definitely be providing you out of the
theater review like we do so ladies and gentlemen
what did you think about the trailer though leave
your thoughts down below please go ahead leave a
like on this video be sure to subscribe do all
those fun things and also if you are going to be
at Comic-Con please stop by and lastly add a soda
shirt only available for a little bit of time so
please go ahead if you are interested in getting
one get one now talk with you guys soon [Music]